The Incredible Hulk absolutely dominates
Ghost Rider in this video and it's crazy
check this out so this basically opens
up with Bruce Banner and a girl named
Charlie walking down the road together
now what's going on here because the
last time we covered the Incredible Hulk
he was out there in the Multiverse
fighting different iterations of himself
in effect the Incredible Hulk comic was
relaunched under uh Philip Kennedy
Johnson and right now what's going on is
there's a creature out there called the
eldest and it's basically resurrect
monsters across the globe Charlie is a
girl who was lured into a trap by the
eldest in order to basically take the
Incredible Hulk Persona out of Bruce
Banner and use the Hulk for its own ends
it involved the man things and stuff
like that none of it's really important
here the only thing that's important is
this story kind of feels like a Ghost
Rider story to be honest it feels like a
Ghost Rider comic got some horror
elements to it but in effect like
banners just kind of out there in the
world doing his thing trying to stay
away from everybody so he doesn't become
a danger by turning into the Hulk and
Charlie's accompanying him because she's
got nowhere else to go and the two of
them are trying to find the eldest so
but what they end up doing is coming
across this group of workers with a
little kid who's just kind of like
heading out east right in order to
basically find some work right they go
to a town they set up shop and so banner
and them agree to basically ride with
these folks to the nearest town which is
about 30 miles away but they tell them
they have to crash somewhere at night
because they can't stay out on the open
road that something hunts in the night
and so what this does is this picks up
in the local town about 30 Mi West and
what we end up getting is this guy who
really just kind of seems to meet with
his wife or whoever this person happens
to be and says hey I'm going out for
basically therapy right group therapy
and then probably play some bowling
afterwards uh I'll be back when I'm done
but he kind of has this Vision where he
just freaks out on his wife but then
just sort of walks away right now in the
midst of all this as he's driving he
gets like these really dark visions and
the reason why is because his mind kind
of snaps and becomes someone else
momentarily it's not Ghost Rider it's a
whole different being that we'll talk
about here in a minute but this guy
seems to kind of try to keep himself in
check to a degree right like we are not
the things that we've done we are not
the things that have been done to us our
service had meaning our lives have value
basically the guy's a former serviceman
and so to a degree You could argue that
he's struggling with PTSD but there's
something much much bigger a foot here
because he ends up pulling over out in
the desert to try to regain his
composure right switch back over to the
Incredible Hulk or really Bruce Banner
along with everybody else now because
the Incredible Hulk is a credible threat
because there's no real knowing what it
is that it's going to do it's one of the
things that Philip Kennedy Johnson in a
lot of ways is kind of returning to the
idea that like when the Incredible Hulk
takes over who knows what's going to
happen as opposed to like I'm the
Incredible Hulk and I'm going to go into
the Multiverse and fight different
versions of myself instead it's very
much back to Roots right the classic
version of Incredible Hulk storytelling
which is why when he's invited to
basically spend time with these people
and their safety and numbers and they
kind of tell him like you shouldn't
stray too far by yourself his response
is no no no no it's cool if I give you
folks a little bit of space plus it's
the Incredible Hulk right I mean like
what's anything going to do to him and
so what you do is you switch over to
Charlie as she walks up and talks to
this kid who's sitting next to like this
World War II era Harley-Davidson it's
old school but it's really kind of a
weird conversation because this kid says
it's Uncle s's but it's mine too and
when she asked the question like Uncle s
he says yeah he rides it when the
monsters come he's like an angel except
mean and she kind of laughs to herself
for a second and she's like I kind of
know a guy like that too right obviously
referring to Bruce Banner at that point
the older woman in the group comes over
to Banner and offers him some food but
in the midst of all of this the whole
Persona starts to take over and kind of
taunts Banner to a degree right like you
never learn do you kindness from
strangers watching kids play minute to
catch your breath that's all over for
you there's only me now run Banner
unless you want your new friends to pay
along with you right and so in that
moment the motorbike lights up right
like the motorcycle just catches on fire
and ignites and the whole idea behind
this right like what this kid tells
Charlie is that when the monsters come
that's when the bike ignites right he
says a big for real monster came it took
David away but Uncle s heard it now
whenever it comes s scares it away and
that's when the motorcycle lights up and
that's when the kids's like he's coming
right s only comes when something bad is
close when the monsters are close and so
immediately it hits to Charlie okay we
got to go get Banner only for her to see
that his clothes have all basically been
shed and that Banner has transformed
into the Incredible Hulk now the way in
which he does this this is where like
the horror element comes in because it's
not like one of those things where it's
a traditional like transform
it's like he's shedding his skin so to
speak and like emerging from Banner
himself it's really really cool but also
kind of dark at the same time but Hulk
kind of taunts Banner right like you
never really learned you should have
stayed away and so what ends up
happening is out of nowhere this
motorcycle just comes riding down the
road with this guy dressed in this like
World War II Garb like brandishing a
Thompson machine gun and like runs over
the Hulk and sprays him down right now
this guy has no clue what he's dealing
with right and like literally the Hulk
says like you're no Ghost Rider that
I've ever seen and the guy says I look
out for the kid say your prayers ugly
you sleep in Hell tonight right so it's
like one of those crazy moments now
here's the thing and it's something that
I do love about this one of the things
to know is that in Marvel Comics there
have been a lot of Ghost Riders over the
years the three most popular right now
and the three main ones that you see are
Johnny blae Danny catch and Robbie Reyes
but but there have been other Ghost
Riders before them right it's one of the
big expansions to the Ghost Rider Mythos
is that it wasn't as though just Johnny
blae became Ghost Rider one day and that
was it it was very much like what Matt
fraction did with the uh what is it the
immortal weapons right like the whole
iron fist thing that like Danny Rand was
just the most recent iteration of the
Iron Fist before him it was Orson
Randall it's very similar to that right
just a history of Ghost Riders who by
whatever Manner and whatever means
somehow had their souls bonded to a
demon entity like in the case of Johnny
Blaze and Mesto or with like an actual
demonic being in the case of Robbie
Reyes but whatever the case is right
this dude just like sprays down the Hulk
now the funny thing about this is that
Ghost Rider did not manifest because of
the Hulk Ghost Rider manifested because
of this demonic being that's watching
them fight so again there was an actual
reason why it's here it just doesn't
realize the reason for why it's here but
as for the fight between the two of them
it goes exactly the way that you think
it would this monstrous being makes
itself known and we'll talk about it
here in a second because it's
technically called a war devil I think
that's the actual name given to it but
it's also brand new that we don't really
specifically know exactly what it's
called or if it even has a proper name
but the fight between Ghost Rider and
Hulk man it goes exactly the way that
you think it would man like this thing
runs up on Hulk with a motorcycle the
Hulk just like smashes the motorcycle
right and then it just reconstitutes
itself because you know it's the Ghost
Rider it can do stuff like that and then
the Ghost Rider tells him like touch
that kid and I'll put you in the ground
the response to the Hulk is like I don't
even know who you're talking about man
and just like smacks this guy around
some more right Hulk just just dominates
this I mean it's like child's play for
the Hulk to deal with this guy it's not
even anything he'd concern himself with
and what this does is it establishes the
vast difference and power between this
Ghost Rider and someone like Johnny
Blaze for example because like during
World War Hulk The Incredible Hulk at
his absolute strongest if memory serves
me correctly and in my old age maybe I'm
forgetting but Ghost Rider dominated him
I mean absolutely crushed World breaker
Hulk and it wasn't even close right like
we covered that well you'll find the
link to that in the Incredible Hulk
playlist at the end of this video but
the fact is the fact that this Ghost
Rider is getting crushed by the Hulk
just getting dominated so readily it
just shows this guy's nowhere near on
the same level so I wouldn't say he's
like some kind of standin Ghost Rider
right Like a Ghost Rider of the moment
he's probably going to play a more
significant role and probably end up
like joining the group of Charlie and
and banner himself but to the bigger
Point here when this monstrous entity
makes itself known it starts attacking
everybody and initially goes after
Charlie only for Ghost Rider to abandon
the fight with the Hulk snatch this
thing up drag it through the dirt and
then of course Hulk comes back and
finishes the job right like this thing
initially gets stabbed and Hulk's just
like no we're not playing this game now
the Hulk does recognize ize it right and
it says you're one of hers where's
eldest and the response this thing gives
him man has no place in the garden so
the response The Incredible Hulk okay
cool man well if that's how you're going
to be then there's no point in you just
living anymore so the Hulk helps him
finish with all his living and that's
basically it and so what you get here is
this kind of switch over to this moment
right because the Ghost Rider basically
goes back to its normal self right it
just kind of disappears right back into
the motorcycle presumably and you switch
over to basically like this town right
the town that this being this monster
kind of originally came from and what
you have here is like this group where
all these guys are talking to each other
right anybody want to talk first y'all
know I serve with Harold Harold of
course being the guy that we saw at the
beginning who said he was going to go
bowling and stuff like that he's the
monster right he is that monster that
was attacking everybody kind of like a
Dr Jackal Mr High type thing right this
guy says he was a great Soldier knew the
meaning of service better than anybody
and knew the cost of it he struggled
when he came back like we all did worse
maybe the nightmares never really went
away for him he deserved a hell of a lot
better than to die of a stroke at his
age and another guy chimes in and says
Herold should have had a long life full
of grandkids birthdays cookouts right
quiet peaceful nights no more nightmares
of screaming in the desert maybe he's
got that now but the kicker here is that
they say a kind of prayer and then
suddenly this substance just starts
oozing out of like every orifice their
eyes their ears the whole nine yards and
the eldest makes its presence known and
it says foul ravagers gluttonous
devourers unbidden trespassers locusts
insatiable how I despise you as I
despise your slain fellow but he was
mine to slay they who failed him are
known to me Hunters of devils and men
from across the sea take the gifts I
here bestow and in turn it bonds its
abilities to them right and water my
garden with their blood like that's what
it says in essence it's a very long
winded and overly fancy way of saying
they were turned into henchmen and so
you switch back over right to this kind
of makeshift campsite with like Banner
or really just the Hulk who's kind of in
its current form you do get this really
really interesting conversation between
Hulk and Charlie where like she asked
the question uh so like where does
Banner go whenever you manifest right
like if you're here
where's he at and we actually end up
finding out that Banner is just kind of
locked in the mindscape essentially it's
one of those interesting depictions for
those of you guys who don't know the way
in which the relationship between banner
and Hulk Works regarding like where one
of them is when the other one is quote
unquote in control it changes from one
comic to the next right there's some
instances like if you go and look at
Hulk the end that like Banner is kind of
just in this ethereal black space right
just like Eternal Darkness he's just
kind of there in the mind watching
everything happen through Hulk's eyes so
it all just kind of depend right on on
who's writing the comic who's drawing
the comic and what the main motivation
is here but the bigger point that it's
making is that Banner is basically a
prisoner but of course Hulk always
hating Banner simply says like do not
talk about banner and then you have this
guy who looks at the Hulk's eyes and
realizes they've turned black and Hulk
hears this kind of voice right ravaging
brute you have no place in my garden and
that's when the eldest makes its
presence known in so far as saying like
Hulk I'm coming for you and so that's
when Charlie's just kind of like okay
whatever that thing was it infected him
or something like that like Hulk is not
his normal self they tell everybody like
get the kids out of here as fast as you
can right like this thing has come back
the war devil has returned except now
there's seemingly three of them right
three of these monsters so the question
has to be asked what in the world
happens in the midst of all this I don't
know it's a really interesting take on
the Hulk let me know what you guys think
down in the comment section about this
right I'm kind of curious but we're
going to bring this to and if you guys
need to get caught up on the Incredible
Hulk make sure you guys click the link
to this playlist and I will catch you
all later peace